today I'm announcing that I will not be
seeking re-election
and then my team as prime minister will
conclude no later than the 7th of
February
a tough moment Jacinda ardern calling it
a day
I am leaving
because with such a privileged role
comes responsibility
the responsibility to know when you are
the right person to lead and also when
you are not
I know what this job takes and I know
that I no longer have enough in the tank
to do it justice it's that simple
over the Christmas break I don't hope to
find a way to carry on but she was
burned out and who could blame her
steering the country through crisis
after crisis
in 2019 a white supremacist killed 51
people in the Christchurch Massacre
from our journey empathy and compassion
when the pandemic hit she told new
zealanders they would go hard and go
early slamming the borders shut for
almost two years
young charismatic
she made the world stop and take notice
of New Zealand and from new zealanders
pride and surprise at the news I think
she's
booked after the country over some
pretty difficult times so um yeah kind
of wish her all the best for the future
I think she needs a break to be honest
yeah she's done a lot
but will it be enough for Arden's labor
party to win October's general election
it's likely to be close labor is down in
the polls there's a cost of living
crisis and surprise Arden is not
sticking around for the vote you had
told me at the start of the day our Doom
was going to resign it would have been
like nah no way no way because we're
that we just would expect her to have
run this election potentially lost this
next election but we were all expecting
her to run this election and give it her
all but for our turn in the end family
came first
insert an eve mum is looking forward to
being there when you start school this
year
enter Clark
let's finally get married
and maybe now there'll be time for that
Nicole Johnston Sky News Sydney